and do you remember how like your
courtship
uh went down it's very old-school
haitian courtship i i love you recorded
her for
nine months
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming
queen a girl who absolutely was
in a ska band called sitting walrus
elise morales
and with us today guys we have such
a funny comedian he's a comic whose work
you've read in the new york times
his special january 3rd is out right
now on amazon prime but before
all of that he was a graduate of saint
louis de gonzag
it's tj thank you very much well done
you did a good job with that name i know
it's very daunting
i was when i was coming into the episode
because i knew that
you grew up in haiti and as we discussed
you are our first international guest
i was i was worried about the french
because i'll say
i'm that i took spanish in school so i
do not have
any passion
so as we said you went to high school in
haiti so before we get into
even like anything what is the structure
of haitian
high school like what are the grade
levels what do you call them how
how does that line up to you age-wise
uh it's basically uh well i don't know
if you're familiar with french but it's
structured after
french schooling okay so
you get high school is four years okay
so you get to uh i'm trying to translate
this if it's gonna work
but i guess
and that lines up to with freshman
whatever yeah you got sophomore junior
scene here okay
cool so it's similar to what we're
dealing with over here
so did you go was the school structured
around like where you live like did you
go to school with other kids
nearby was it is it like a public school
system or
are they religious in any way like how
does that match up
religious very religious okay and they
have
the best schools i'm not a big fan of
catholicism but
catholic schools in haiti are the best
schools
ever and i was lucky enough to go to a
catholic school and
it's very rigid they give you the best
education they prepare you for the world
and i'm very grateful that i went to one
of those yeah
so what do you feel like made it
get actually prepare you for the world
like what aspects of it
the the basic stuff like the the level
of
math i got like when i the s80 was
fairly easy for me
uh when i came to america things were
fairly easy like
i got old math i know now there's new
math i don't even know
what that means but you've heard of this
concept right
yeah i have not kept up with what's
going on in math like if you give me a
piece of paper i can do
like multiplication and division the old
school way and i'll be
fine but if you put a 15 year old in
front of me
and tell him to like show this kid how
to do new math i'll be like this is
chinese i have no idea what you're doing
so
okay let's let now that we've kind of
painted the picture here so team team tj
what is team tj into what are his
uh interests oh my god i was
how do i even put this i was what you
would call
a a social nerd
okay yeah i was very i'm i was a
valedictorian i was good at school
okay but i wasn't socially
like weird like the dude with glasses
who's a virgin that kind of stuff
i luckily for me i wasn't that
so i was a nerd with some sort of
credibility in the streets
okay okay
a nerd with street credibility
did you do like were you like focused
academically or did you play sports
anything like that
what was like the big sport to play at
your high school
uh soccer you know football so yeah we
love that and i played some basketball
but i mostly played soccer and i was
just
i was class president i was very
involved and it's kind of annoying now
that i'm a comedian because when i was
in high school
i would have funny thoughts all the time
but i could never express them because i
was in charge of
reigning in the funny kids because
teachers trusted me and wanted me to
keep order and stuff and i was like but
i kind of want to be with those guys
in my head but i couldn't do it because
i had a responsibility it was very
frustrating
so as class president that you also
had a like like a moral leadership
role because i feel i feel like our
class president planned like one dance
and that was it but this was this was a
serious a role that you took very
seriously oh pretty yeah pretty
seriously i went to an old boys school
so there was a lot of
like alpha male energy and just
managing the bunch of dudes can be like
a hassle for sure
so it was it was a lot wow so to be so
you were
the class president uh valedictorian all
of this stuff
was there i always asked this when
someone went to like an all-boys school
was there like an all-girls school that
you guys
like mostly got your girlfriends from
yep we had multiple of those we had
several
sister schools and what's funny about it
was
that those are the official schools
where guys have girlfriends
and then there were other schools around
you know lower status where you would go
and have
side chicks so there was actually a
ranking
see this is the [ __ ] about high school
that i love it's the worst
so did you did you date when you were in
high school
i did i did i had my first girlfriend in
uh
uh premiere which is i guess the year
before the final year that's
junior i guess yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that was when i had my first girlfriend
it was from her sister's school she went
to an all girls school
yeah and do you remember how like your
courtship
uh went down oh my god
it's very old-school haitian courtship
i love that
but that's the thing that's because this
is a nice girl she's from the nice
school this isn't one of the side chick
school girls that's right
you gotta put in work just conversations
on the phone
every night just getting to know each
other
can't wait to get home from school and
call your
girl well she wasn't your girl yet but
the girl you courting
so you you put in all of that work for
as long as you can as long as you still
like each other
and then one day you're like do you want
to be my girlfriend or
girlfriend she's like yeah i like you
enough and i think you've put in enough
work yes
you can be my boyfriend okay cool
and how long did this relationship
last
it lasted three months oh
but was it one of the was it like the
most passionate three months like
oh my god when you're in high school you
think the first time you love
is the last time you'll ever love
so like there's that pressure and drama
added to it
i still get embarrassed remembering
being 14
and telling my aunt that my boyfriend
was the one
i was like he's the one i met him and my
aunt was like
yeah yeah definitely i will
never date another man as long as i live
this is my prince
nice like it's we're in the same biology
class
and if that's not fate i don't
he's got little glasses i love him
yeah it was really cool like i remember
the excitement of you know
like the when there were parties and
then my school got invited and her
school also gets invited so you're like
oh we're gonna meet all the girls from
her school but i don't care about the
other girls i'm gonna meet her because
she gets to be there too
and we're gonna get a little corner to
ourselves and just dance
all night and make out making out had so
much power and you weren't a teenager
oh my god and like you would really
like do like go at making out like
really
in a committed way that i don't hours
your mouth
would go numb and it hurts to a point
where yeah like i don't sustain
injuries from making out the way i did
well it sounds like you weren't
committing enough
i did back in the day back in the day i
you know i put in some work at some
movie theaters
but you're a movie theater
making out girl okay yes i definitely
made out in a lot of
movie theaters i and like basements
people's basements a lot a lot of making
out there
what where were your makeout spots a lot
of parties
and you know just can't wait when
there's a party and they're just gonna
go find each other and make out
yeah yep it were these like school
sanctioned parties
or like off campus like some way off
campus no school function at all they
would never let us
have a party with the girls because they
knew i was trouble yeah
so they wouldn't if there weren't like
oh we're gonna do a dance with the boys
school in the girls school these were
like
you guys were having are you drinking
and stuff at these parties
yes and the good thing about being
haitian is we don't have the 21
like age limits oh so when can you drink
in haiti
uh whenever you can reach the bar that's
the same
if you're old enough and tall enough to
reach the bar then you can have a drink
so was it like frowned upon for you to
be doing that
at all not really because i don't think
we have a big
alcohol culture like we don't have a big
college culture like that even weed weed
was unknown to me for a long time
like not until senior year i heard of
people smoking weed so it's not so it
wasn't
yeah yeah that's so that's so
interesting because here it's such
it's such an intense deal but i do
always wonder if a lot of that is fueled
by the fact that we're like not supposed
to drink till we're 21
and so you start i think so once you put
that pressure on it oh this is something
i cannot
do i'm gonna [ __ ] do it yeah and i'm
gonna do it in the craziest
way too i'm gonna butt chug and do all
kinds of stuff
yes yeah exactly and like just lose
lose my mind okay so you guys you guys
met at uh the dances did you do like
prom and stuff at your school or is that
just a complaint
you didn't promise me i was in charge of
like getting prom together as the
president i had to like
find a ban to play our prom party and
it was a lot of work and responsibility
i kind of
i don't miss it it was too much work it
felt like i wasn't able to enjoy the
night i'm like man i wish i was a
president tonight i would just want to
let loose and chill yeah so you see
i mean it really seems like you had a
major
leadership role at your school
was that something that you liked like
did you want to be
in charge of things uh
i guess on some level i wanted to but
it's also something people just put on
me they were like
you should be in charge you know if
if you have good grades and you know you
kind of carry yourself with some decency
people just
choose you to be a leader yeah it's kind
of annoying
so they were just like you're the one
yeah
yeah and what about your parents are
they were they
strict parents did they were they super
like did they really want you to be
doing this did they
could they care less well the the thing
is
i for high school i moved to
port-au-prince which is the capital of
haiti
and i left my hometown where my parents
still live so i moved to port-au-prince
to live with an
aunt oh okay and she was the coolest
on ever so there was almost no rules i
just had to be responsible
you know just don't drink and drive
don't do anything crazy but you can go
wherever you want and be an adult
that's it's interesting that with all of
that
you chose to like be class president
become
valedictorian all of that stuff because
i feel like
the stereotype for a kid would be oh
he's gonna go crazy
yeah this makes me sound like a knock
doesn't it
no i think i think it makes you seem
like a very self-motivated
individual yeah i am i am
so what what was your relationship to
comedy or
performing at all at this time
not much because
uh we don't really have stand up comedy
like that in haiti
we have it a little bit now but at the
time when i was there i was in high
school in
2007 2008 we didn't really have it
and it's not something i had fallen in
love with yet
so there was performance there was
theater there were plays there were
stuff like that
and i wouldn't say i was much of a
performance guy but i
always had like creative ideas i was
pretty artsy i wrote a lot i wasn't uh
okay this is gonna be interesting i was
in a poetry group with a bunch of boys
we just wrote poetry and compared poetry
together
the dead poets society basically yes
yes oh my god you were in a little
haitian dead poet society that's
beautiful yeah now i'm adult enough to
admit you know it wasn't gay i actually
liked it back in the day i was like this
is kind of gay this is weird
was it i mean there's
there's something slightly gay about
being in a secret poet society of all
boys but
it's [ __ ] you know what hey that's fine
let it be
gay we just love language we just love
writing poetry
yeah um so were and you would you guys
like share your own work with each other
pretty much yeah yeah encourage each
other like oh this is really good you're
getting better at this all right write
another one and then bring it on monday
so we can compare
yeah this is literally the dead poet
society i'm dying
so where would you get did you guys like
have a meeting place
yeah well the school i went to we we
were we went to school from
eight to four okay so
yeah it was all day and between 12 and 1
30 we had a long 90 minute recess
that's so nice very nice i was very
lucky to have that and we get to play
sports and compare poetry and talk about
girls and talk about movies that was the
time where you get to
let it all out yeah oh that honestly
that sounds
so lovely and so much better than what
we did which was like
seven to two but you just went through
the entire time we were never allowed to
leave
campus uh sometimes we had lunch at 10
a.m because
oh my god you should have went to high
school in haiti i'm sorry
it really it really sounds like uh i
should have gone
to high school in haiti uh so okay you
have some pictures that you sent i think
it's time for us to go through
and and really dive in and get the full
picture so first of all
i do love when someone includes like a
baby picture because we need
so that we can get to the bottom of this
because you
already look like a young scholar in
this baby picture
tiny scholar uh this i must have been uh
five or six this was um
i want to say what comes after
kindergarten
i think first grade so i think it might
have been my first
one yeah my first great picture like
they just put
you behind this big library so you look
like you smart you're in front of books
yeah and as you can tell here i don't
think they
ma my mom didn't put lotion on my legs
so very ashy gay little boy
oh i don't know who told me to strike
that pose
but it's it's pretty gay it is striking
it's a very um it's you look
very serious and i think it reminds me
that
i think it's really funny that we make
little kids take these like serious
scholarly
photos like i have one when i'm about
this
age where i'm wearing like a
full gras graduation cap and gown
what i'm graduating from no one knows
and i'm also sitting in a little library
what is this i'm smirking a little but
i'm also working on the cure for cancer
this is the kind of kid that i
am yes you look like um like a show
would be like this kid's actually a
doctor and you would like come in
young sheldon this is what this
this is young sheldon okay so we've got
the full picture of young sheldon
let's go to the next one here
okay now we're in high school
yeah this is i want to say first year of
high school
and called what again
yes i love it and uh
so did you have did you have a uniform
wherever you went to school
so i um i had a uniform really briefly
when i lived in california and went to
public school out there but i did not
have one at my high school oh okay yeah
i was lucky enough most schools in haiti
do have uniform my school we just wore
clothes
jeans and just t-shirts every day that's
so surprising because i feel like
i i feel like catholic schools in the us
are like the most likely to have the
uniform
yes most catholic schools in haiti do
have uniform but for some reason that
one
they just didn't do it and it was the
coolest thing ever because of that
so what was your like team style because
i honestly feel like right here in this
picture you look slick
like most people show up they look
embarrassing and crazy you look like
a nice young man yeah that was there was
at the time it was cool to have a white
sea underneath your main shirt
even though it was hot as [ __ ] but we
just didn't it was cool you just like
all right i got my white tea
got a little nice 90s going on here was
what's cool
yeah yeah i was like i was like i just
feel like your collar is
crisp like this is actually this
like this looks like a picture that you
could
make the cover of like an album
you know what i mean and it's like
it could be actually it could be tj yeah
parental
and guidance explicit content
yeah the face looks like like i'm not
totally happy there's a little hint of
like i don't know what i'm
being morals about but there's something
i'm like
i'm kind of melancholic yeah and you
really are looking right down the barrel
like right into the soul of the camera
i didn't have a girlfriend there so
could i have been sadness from being
alone yeah it's the deep loneliness of
having never had a girlfriend
um did you guys do like a yearbook and
all that jazz as well i mean it seems
like you're doing school fun we did
we did yeah beautiful beautiful and do
you sign
each other's yearbooks yep yep
one of my favorite memories was well
that was before high school i broke my
arm
so i had a cast and i got all my friends
to just
write nice stuff on it and it was the
coolest stuff ever
oh yeah and it like it makes you feel
so it turns such a shitty thing into
such a cool thing
when you're a kid to be like okay i
sustained an injury but now everyone's
gonna write on my cast
yeah i'm a hero now come write your
little messages to me
yeah i never i like
never injured myself because i
never like put myself out there to be
injured i'm like very physically
living too safe man it's not too late
you could go out and break a bone this
is a good time for it you're gonna be
inside anyway
i know and i'm also worried that because
i've never broken one that when i
finally do i'm like really gonna [ __ ]
myself up like it's gonna be really
really bad
and what if it happened in the most
ridiculous way you're taking a shower
and fall like an old lady
and oh that's your caliber that's
how it's going to happen i'm going to
like take a hit of my vape pen and walk
into a door like it's not
it's not going to be cool at all it's
going to be so messed up
crazy all right let's look at this next
photo
okay so who do we have here
this was one of my best friend in high
school that's when we first discovered
the gym
and decided working out was a cool thing
to do because you know you get some
muscles on and you
a little bit more impressive to the
ladies yeah that was us pretending to be
big boys right there
yeah you like again both of you have a
very like like oh
us we just haven't you're just catching
us in the gym
yeah we're just hey man just doing what
we do just doing what we do
oh i just sorry i'm just really
dedicated to working out
yeah did your school have like a full
like weight lifting
gym they did not but this specific gym
where i was was
a few blocks from my school so after
school we would go and work out
oh okay so yeah why don't you
what were like the after school hangs
for
you and your boys a lot of it
was waiting on campus just sitting
waiting for your parents to come pick
you up
so much of adolescence is sitting
waiting for your parents to come
pictures
just sitting and finding all kinds of
activities to kill the time
and you know you'd have one car and then
a parent would pick up 12 kids
neighboring kids whose parents didn't
have a car they didn't have time to pick
them up
that was a real community thing going on
yeah was cool
that so you guys would like
carpool together kind of like to and
from school depending
mm-hmm yeah did it was like a school bus
a thing or because i guess ultimately
that was our version of that was just
yeah not really but you had this thing
called uh a tap tap
it's like a little pickup truck i don't
know if you've ever seen that and then
they create
like a little roof a little enclosure on
top of it
so i think i've seen that on the anthony
bourdain episode where he goes
yep and people will come you paid two
dollars you get to sit in the back and
take a ride and then you go to school
yeah that's oh that's so cool yeah see
we like
i feel like when i was growing up high
schoolers and in the us
maybe and like definitely in like
suburban virginia where i grew up
the idea that you would like let high
schoolers get on public transportation
or like
let them have an hour in the middle of
the day where we didn't like
keep complete close tabs on them or that
they would be allowed to drink if they
wanted to
was so far outside of what was
happening at all yeah what what town in
virginia did you go to high school to
oh in uh my my high school was called
oakton and it was in oakton and then i'm
from franklin farm
okay i have a cousin who currently lives
in colonial heights which is okay
45 minutes i think outside of richmond
are you familiar yeah
well so my sister went to school in
richmond virginia is like
the biggest state it is you
realize is enormous and it's actually so
it's so huge but i was up north by like
the dc
area which is very like all of the
all of the families in that area like
their parents work for the government
they're very like it's just like a very
uptight like buttoned up
area where you would never let high
schoolers
you're like very worried about what high
schoolers are up to were you guys super
religious
no i mean i would say the area was like
is like vaguely white christian
people but my family wasn't religious
and i went to a public school
so it wasn't like i wasn't in like a
religious constitution
were you what so like you were saying
your school was super religious so did
you have like
mass at school and stuff there's a
chapel at
my school that's how religious they are
that's the little chapel so you don't
have to even travel too far for the mass
you go and then you do it
and we had the whole thing during the
month of may
which is it's a catholic school the
month of may is the month of the virgin
mary
okay and then you gotta recite 10
hail marys every single [ __ ] day
for all 31 days in the month of
may and i'm like by the second day
mary's like all right we get it get off
my back already get off my dick please i
don't need more prayers i'm
good that was a lot are the
teachers like are you is this a catholic
school where like you fully have like
nuns as teachers or are the teachers
are the teachers priests or are they
just like other catholics there were a
few
there were a lot of laymen and there
were a few teachers who were
uh they're not priests the brothers it
was a different type of congregation
yeah they were brothers and sisters yeah
okay and what and you said that it was
like
strict so if you like [ __ ] around at
your school
what was what was the punishment well
the worst kind is
you get expelled you're out of school
but uh sometimes they would like for
minor things you might get lines
oh okay so like writing you have to
write
i will never put my finger in
this teacher's face 200 times you'll
never do that
you know that kind of stuff which is a
punishment yeah but
yeah i feel it feels very like old
school
yeah very it's like it's like the
closest we can get to corporal
punishment but we also want to teach you
how to get better at cursive that's the
vibe of it
yeah and did you have like a bible
class or like a religion class
yep every year every single year you get
a religious class teaching you about
catholicism and why
catholicism is the best religion ever
it's basically
indoctrination and did you
did you feel that way about the class
then or were you just like
yeah check that out because there's
definitely nothing bad about catholicism
there were a few rebels back then and i
was definitely
one of them but i had to be quiet
because i was also responsible and that
really
like dampened my ability to speak my
[ __ ]
but yeah it felt that way back then and
you know
the the the stuff about you know
especially catholic schools
like all right let me say the catholic
schools have
such a good education you almost forget
that they [ __ ] kids you forget all the
other [ __ ]
that they do because you enjoying being
in school so much you like they taught
me latin
i mean they touch my friend but i learn
latin which one is more important i
don't know
it's hard i mean
like there are there are places that
don't give you a good
education and still [ __ ] kids so
you know so all things considered like
oh boy okay
i hope you don't have to cut that out
i'm sorry no i don't think
we're leaving it in oh we're leaving it
in
um what i was gonna
ask you was did you get in any trouble
when you were in school or were you kind
of able to evade
that i got in some minor trouble nothing
really
big like to the point of like they had
to call your parents
and not really i got in minor trouble
yeah
for like talking back or
yeah talking back i remember like i
started to being
to be a rebel in senior year and i
wasn't happy
like especially as the president i
wasn't happy with everything the
the lead the principal was doing he was
very strict and he was kind of
hypocritical in the way he was doing
things
and i remember i wrote a very strongly
worded
letter that i was gonna send him
and i showed it to a bunch of my friends
they were like yes we all support this
we're gonna sign it we
behind you and then i shared it with one
of
my teachers and he was like listen i
i agree with this i don't think it's
good for your future
to send this to him and he
talked me out of it
and to this day sometimes i wonder
what would have happened if i had sent
him would that have changed the
trajectory of my life
yeah that's so interesting so do you
what was it that set off
you writing the letter what was his
behavior
uh just the way he was treating us he
was managing us with
fear as opposed to mutual respect like
you don't do
if you do this this will happen if you
do that that will happen and i was like
look man we're [ __ ] adults
so we drink we go to parties bud
yeah we're fingering people we're in
high school
i take the bus here like exactly
i'm going to parties talking to my
girlfriend every night i have a
girlfriend bro don't treat me like this
yeah i'm a man i have a woman
um so i mean okay this is super
interesting to me uh do
you i guess what do you think
could have like the principal could have
done that would have changed the
trajectory of your life
uh i don't think the letter was enough
for him to expel
me but i think he
possibly could have removed the prom
privileges from us
because of that letter oh like
he would have been like oh you want me
to respect you
for you okay respect this yeah
i think you could have done that and you
know maybe your woman to the parking lot
tj
[Laughter]
yeah and i think if if that happened the
boys probably would be mad at me for
being the
leader who did not get them their prom
party for it with
them and their girlfriend so yeah it's
it's like
interesting but like what if i wonder
yeah that is interesting but it it could
have gone
i mean if you ended up being the reason
prom was cancelled
that sucks that would have been a huge
burden oh my god
that would have that would have been
terrible so um
how did you so when your high school
ended was your plan to come to college
in the u.s
did you have you figured out you wanted
to do stand-up at all at this point what
did the end of your
high school career look like i
hadn't figured out stand-up yet but i do
know i
wanted to come to america i had applied
to two schools one in florida one in new
york
the one in new york gave me a half
scholarship so i thought all right i'll
come here so i took my ss and that
and then you gotta go get your i-20 i
don't know if you know what that is it's
the paperwork to get a student visa
okay and then i had to go to the embassy
of the us in haiti
to like have an interview with the
consulate and they would be like okay so
why do you want to come here blah blah
blah
just making sure that you're not going
to come here and have a bunch of kids on
american soil that you actually
come in to be a student mm-hmm yeah
then it's not a 90-day fiance situation
that's right
that's right um were you like
did you have to figure all that stuff
out yourself did your parents or your
aunt help you with that or were you just
kind of like
i guess all right i was fairly
responsible
that i i kind of you know learn from
like older cousins who've done it just
get people to give me advice yeah so i
managed to do it
you know being a president you carry
that stuff on your shoulders yeah
you had you had to go far to represent
the entire class
you had to make it pretty smart yeah
was that like a common thing for kids at
your school to do to like go
out of the country for college or was
that
kind of rare it was
fairly common for my school it's pretty
rare for haiti
but okay we were lucky enough to go to
my school because the religious schools
tend to be for middle class and
rich people something so i was lucky and
privileged in that way that my my
parents really value education
like a lot of the kids i went to school
with were had way more money than me
but my parents they're like we don't
care if we don't have
their level of money but we want to have
access to that level of education so
we'll pay for it
yeah like we'll pay into something
that's maybe actually like
a step above where we're at so that you
exactly
so that you could be better off and then
they did that so now i'm a stand-up
comedian
so the tables have turned
[Laughter]
okay that's so funny
um all right i think you have two more
pictures let's definitely take a look at
them before we
round this out here um
all right where where are you in this
photo
you look like you're calling together
like a meeting
or something this picture
so all right this is gonna sound
very weird to an american
but in haiti the pizza is not
huge so we only had two places where you
could go get pizza
okay and this was one of them me and a
couple of high school friends
one of our very rare pizza nights and we
got to that place
and that look on my face was i kind of
was angry because someone ate my pizza
wow how did this happen
they were just playing around and i'm
like listen you better not [ __ ] touch
my pizza it was a girl so i couldn't
really be that mad
because i'm like all right she i guess
she's a girl
that's a game we women can play
especially in high school yeah yeah
so it was a pizza night at emina's
yeah i remember that and now okay so now
that you've lived in
new york you've had new york pizza how
did the pizza
at this place stack up you know what
it's still pretty good
yeah i think they they knew like you
know this is
a rare thing so we're gonna put elbow
grease into this and make sure
these kids enjoy it if we're going to be
the one place providing teens with pizza
that's right they took like much like
you and your responsibilities as
president they took their symbolic role
there you go exactly all right let's
look at this next photo
okay what what group do we have here
this is a class picture in
the second year of high school
okay so this is like a sophomore
these it's it's really interesting you
guys do
uh there's like three of you in a row
that have like
a collared shirt with a striped pattern
that is tucked in
yeah yeah and this was the so you see
that that older man
on the right that's the teacher of the
day so he took the picture with us
oh who's wait so teacher of the day is
that like
what is that position he was the guy who
was that at the time they was taking
that picture so he just took it with us
it's not a special rule or anything i
thought it was like a special role that
like
every day they'd be like and today the
teacher of the day
yeah this is tuesday's teacher and then
every day everyone takes a picture with
it
yeah it's actually funny there's a
continuity between those pictures
because now if you
you see the dude that sits down kind of
right in front of me
yes that's the dude that i was at the
gym with in the previous picture
there you go and at this point had you
guys started going to the gym
no that was before we were pretty look
at us we're pretty like
feeble here like there's no muscles
nothing
i think we basically looked at the
picture and we're like all right we got
to do something about this
these bodies this is very pitiful
oh my god okay well that's wonderful i
think this is your last photo
i could have said more but i chose five
should have oh that was perfect
no that was perfect don't even worry
about it um so
we're rounding this out here we've got a
picture of this a team tj
he's like super self-motivated uh
he's elite he's a leader he ends up
in new york take us just briefly
through your college journey and how did
you end up
getting into stand-up alright so i got
to the us in 2008
and remember we don't speak english in
haiti
so i'm learning as i got here i'm in
college and i realizing i don't know
what the professors are talking about
most of the time
my four years of english did not prepare
me for this so i was like i gotta go to
work and
not be as an idiot in class so i started
watching a lot of television
lo and behold comedy central was very
hot at the time
ah jon stewart and stephen colbert were
educating me every night about america
and how this country works how the
system works the politics of it while
staying
funny so i was really into like their
sense of humor and i just got into
standup so i started watching every
single piece of stand-up that i could
get my hands on
2008 cat williams very hot
oh my god i uh i would like download
kat williams stand up on like like
illegal limewire and it would like come
through all like crackly and like crazy
yeah he was he was the man around that
time and huge
but the thing is he was uh kind of it
was scary for me watching him because i
was like i like this but i don't know
that i can do it
and then i remember one night i was in
college just you know first year in
america trying to kind of
[ __ ] so i got this girl over to my dorm
and i was like i'm gonna play some
comedy for you so i wouldn't use when
played some cat williams for her and she
was like
and she was like oh this is cool but i
got something even better for you so she
put on
george carlin and i was like
oh this is my first time seeing this
and this looks a little bit more like my
speed
um yeah because yeah like
cat williams is such a specific style of
personal performer he's sweating all
over the place he's got the pimp suit on
he's got perm in his hair and i was like
this is not me i don't have that kind of
energy i could not do this
no no no no but george was a little bit
more cerebral just standing there and
talking [ __ ] about whatever he wanted to
like i remember the ten commitments that
was the bit yeah
the girl put on that night and i was
like oh i like this he's criticizing
religion i've been thinking about this
since high school
but i couldn't do it because i was
president so oh i want to do that
and that was so mesmerizing i almost
forgot i was trying to [ __ ] this girl i
did not even
i found my dreams you and your [ __ ] can
just stay over there i'm good i'm one
yeah actually i'm sorry
you just changed the entire course of my
life so i'm gonna need you to leave
that's pretty much what happened that's
so interesting and i never even i mean
that i'm sure this is for another
podcast but starting comedy in a
language that was not your first
language must have been a unique journey
as well
yeah it was it was very interesting was
pretty terrifying
um you know you get like one of those
things
is like do you ever think about which
language you're dreaming
well i mean i only speak english so i
just don't know
english i know it's like it's so boring
my spanish is like okay but i'm
definitely not dreaming in spanish so
i know that my dad who's bilingual
i think says that he'll dream in spanish
still
yeah i i would dream my whole life in
haitian creole and then i came here
about three weeks in
i had my first dream in english and it
kind of freaked me out and the word
what's weird about it is my parents were
speaking perfect english in the dream
and my parents do not speak a word of
english in real life
i was like what is going on here my
dream parents are scaring me
i guess i'm accepting america so here we
are yeah
um tj you were an amazing guest it was
so awesome to talk to you
uh we round out every episode with this
question which is
if you could talk to tntj today
what would you tell him oh my
oh i mean he seems to like have it
together in a pretty good way
but yeah yeah he was pretty good i would
say uh
you're doing pretty good man just lean
more into
the creativity that's inside of you and
you know live a little bit less for your
parents
live more for yourself yeah did you feel
like
maybe a lot of that stuff that you like
all of the high achieving stuff
you wanted to impress your parents yeah
it made them
happy and proud so i just kept doing it
mostly for them
yeah yeah but you want to be a comedian
and now that i do this they don't know
how to deal with it's like well this is
not making us happy and proud what are
you doing
yeah you spoiled them for years by doing
exactly what they wanted and then
hard pivoted into something that they
don't understand
well um that's i think where we're gonna
end it so tj thanks
so much for coming on the show uh your
special is on
amazon prime right now it's called
january 3rd
correct that is correct yes wonderful
well everyone go check that out and for
everybody listening at home this has
been the roast of your teenage self
[Music]
podcast
you